hello my friends it's been a pretty
memorable year and I am not just
referring to all the new McFlurry
flavors that I discovered nope I am
talking about movies and there were a
bunch of really good ones that came out
in 2023 so before we turn the page in
the calendar that I forgot to buy for
2024 let's just look back one more time
now it's worth noting that today's list
only features wide release films that
hit 3,000 or more theaters and that does
exclude some pretty great titles so be
sure to check out the full list at
Rotten tomatoes.com and while I'm know
that the most memorable Movie experience
of the year for a lot of people was a
little something called barbon Heimer
I'm sad to say that Barbie just barely
missed out on the top 10 and came in at
11 which is frustratingly close for
me but just so you all know it is still
KU in all our hearts so let's check out
the best movies of 2023 right now on
Rotten Tomatoes
countdown
number 10 Dungeons and Dragons honor
among Thieves based on the classic
roleplaying tabletop game but with no
connection to the film Trilogy released
in the 2000s if you know you know this
film arrived in the spring and it
brought a new kind of life to this
long-running franchise the film was
described as a fantasy Heist action
comedy and if that just seems like a
bunch of adjectives thrown together very
true I feel the same but also it really
makes perfect sense once you see it now
our be friend oh let C lasses and LS
where once we contend now our be friend
let's Cate lasses Cate lasses Cate
lasses Cate lasses
what's my f is stuck
concate whatness is
this honor among Thieves features Chris
Pine leading a very strong cast that
includes Michelle Rodriguez and REE Jean
paage and after being in development for
a decade the weights seemed to be worth
it especially because the fans are into
it which really matters with something
like this the film's very high audience
scor is due to fans loving the blend of
action fantasy and comedy all while
respecting The Source material you know
it's like you got to respect the
Dungeons and the dragons you feel
me number nine Megan not that Society
needed another example of how artificial
intelligence could go Oho very wrong but
this movie is just too good not to have
been made it stars Allison Williams as a
toy company roboticist who designs a
life likee doll to serve as a child's
friend and an ally to parents but after
she decides to use the doll on her
orphaned 8-year-old niece things don't
go as planned and when they try to shut
it down well let's just say that this
toy could put toys or us right back out
of
business
paraly a slap right your
face
take going to get you
good
security with Jason Blum and James Juan
Among The film's Producers it's not not
really surprising that this one became a
hit at the box office and with critics
so much so that a sequel already has
been green lit with Alison Williams
returning unless of course some of this
stuff starts happening in real life and
then we're all just going to have to run
as fast as we can in the opposite
direction I will ask chat gbt if that is
likely and get back to
you number eight air this film tells the
incredible true origin story of the
world's most famous Sho line of all time
Air Jordan which seems to be as popular
as ever and in sports other than
basketball the movie Soares with a
stellar cast that includes Matt Damon
Ben Affleck Jason baitman and Viola
Davis among others with Ben Affleck also
directing and honestly it just really
never gets old seeing Affleck and Damon
do their thing I'm willing to bet my
career on Michael Jordan come on man you
ask me what I do here this is what I do
I find you players and I feel it this
time okay it's risky when you were
selling sneakers out of the back of your
Plymouth that was risky it took balls I
mean that's why we're all here here
don't change that now don't I mean if
you look at him if you really look at
Jordan like I did you're going to see
exactly what I see just what the most
competitive guy I have ever seen he is
aing killer not that it matters all that
much in Hollywood but his aess Michael
Jordan did meet with Ben Affleck and
give the movie his Blessing which is
pretty good cuz as we saw in the Last
Dance you do not want to make MJ mad or
he might you know take it personal the
audience score for this one is in the
very very high 990 so if you can't trust
the critics you can most definitely
trust your peers they loved it and I am
one of them I mean just look at my shoes
oh wait these are Adidas just
kidding number seven killers of the
flower
moon this Western crime drama was
directed by Martin scorsi it stars
Leonardo Dicaprio and Robert dairo
making it scorsese's sixth collab with
DiCaprio and 10th with DeNiro I mean
talk about a husband husband husband
work relationship now the killer cast
also includes people like Jesse plem
Brendan Fraser and Lily Gladstone who
along with Leo shines in this one and
has the early Awards Buzz to prove
it what was
that that's how you are I don't know
what you said but must have been Indian
for handsome
devil
sh killers of the flower moon is based
on the 2017 non-fiction book of the same
name by David Gran and it tells the
story of a series of murders in the oage
nation of Oklahoma in the 1920s after
oil was found on tribal land clocking in
at nearly 3 and 1 half hours I got to
say it's a bit intense but the vibe from
audiences is that this powerful story
mixed with Gorgeous scenery and great
acting really helps it move and it's
those three things that will help make
this a force during Awards
season number six
Oppenheimer this biopic was written
produced and directed by Mr Christopher
Nolan who wrote the script in the first
person to really put people in
oppenheimer's shoes now to help with
that he also cast Killian Murphy as
theoretical physicist J Robert
Oppenheimer and the critic's consensus
calls it a Tor to force performance and
I call it really damn good Hitler's dead
it's
true for the Japanese fight on their
defeat seems assured not if you're a GI
preparing to
invade we can end this War but how do we
justify using this weapon on human
beings we're
theorists
yes we imagine a future and our
imaginings horrify us they won't fear it
until they understand it and they won't
understand it until they've used it
Murphy was also joined by names like
Emily Blunt Matt Damon Romy Malik Robert
Downey Jr Josh hartnet and Kenneth BR in
reporting roles and while yeah I'm so
sorry that is a lot of names I mean who
am I going to leave off that list Josh
no way and Oppenheimer actually checks
in as the highest grossing film on this
list at nearly a billion dollars made
and if I had just made a billion dollars
I would bet some of it on that you'll
hear this movie called on Oscar night
way more than once holy New Year we have
reached the halfway point and because
short-term memory loss is a side effect
of those special gummies your neighbor
probably gave you here is a recap so
what is left let's find out number five
John Wick chapter 4 with star Keana
Reeves and director Chad stahelski
returning a full four years after the
release of chapter 3 Parabellum many
critics call this the best John Wick of
them all if not one of the best action
movies of all time wowza not only that
this time around it manages to weave in
a thoughtful story amongst a fun new set
of characters which includes action
Legend Donnie
Yen
if it seems like this franchise is at
the top of its game it absolutely is
luckily a spin-off and technically a
prequel to this movie called ballerina
is set for 2024 while a fifth Wick film
is also in development I mean all this
over a dead
puppy number four Spider-Man across the
spiderverse Miles Morales AKA Spider-Man
returned this year with the impossible
task of living up to the first movie
Spider-man into the spiderverse and they
totally did it in this one miles and
Gwen Stacy Venture into the spiderverse
where Miles meets a group of spider
Heroes called the spider society and he
buds heads with one of them over how to
deal with a new villain the spot
Spider-Man wow this is is real so are
you like a cow or a Dalmatian I
am the spot we meet again
Spider-Man oh that's funny to you of
course not no so is that a costume
unfortunately for both of us this is
skin oh dang you see I'm from your past
one year ago hold up oh come on uhoh now
much like the first movie this one
performed extremely well for for an
animated action flick and for many
reasons one of which is the voice cast
which saw names like Issa Ray Daniel Kya
Jason schwarzman and Oscar Isaac joining
up with returning Stars Shmi Moore Haley
Steinfeld and Jake Johnson now a third
movie is in development to make it a
Trilogy along with a more female Centric
Spidey spin-off too so get
excited number three Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles muttin Mayhem clearly it
was a very big year for animated action
this one performed even better better
with critics than Spider-Man the four
main characters the turtles are voiced
by newcomers in an effort to cast actual
teenagers and then you have AO ad Dey
playing April O'Neal Ice Cube who's the
main villain Superfly and Jackie Chan is
Master Splinter the Turtle sensei and
adopted
father boys where have you been I've
been freaking out we're sorry Dad it was
this one cat and you know I'm scared of
cat so we did have wait a second you
said you would go shopping then come
right back where were you uh look we're
really sorry Splinter some of the guys
want to see a movie and I try to talk
him out of it what you watch a movie
with a
humans you red us out hey don't use that
word that way that was I me sorry Dad
producer Seth Rogan teamed up with his
longtime collaborator Evan Goldberg from
movies like super bad to co-write this
one which ultimately caters to both kids
and parents he also got a bunch of his
friends to voice characters including
Paul Rudd and Rose Burn along with other
big names like post Malone and the best
bad guy ever Jean Carlos Pito I mean
Turtle Power sorry I've just always
wanted to say that on camera number two
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one now Ethan Hunt returned yet again
and this time no seriously this time it
was his most dangerous Mission yet until
dead reckoning part two I presume uh in
part one hunt and friends are looking to
track down a dangerous weapon that
threatens Humanity before the bad guys
get it no big deal and a big part of
that plan involves a fresh new face of
the franchise Haley
Atwell there's a cylindrical device
inside I'm I'm I'm going to take it
out how we doing Luther Ethan the
buyer's in the waiting area above you
top of the
escalator all the units are headed in
your direction your location is going to
be crawling with agents anytime
now her character is a thief with her
own agenda and she joined returning
characters in Ethan Circle played by the
likes of Ving RS Simon Peg and Rebecca
Ferguson an expensive budget and other
competition this summer AKA barbin
Heimer made this a bit of a
disappointment at the box office but as
you can see it made number two on this
list number one are you there God it's
me Margaret this coming of age dramedy
is of course based on the 1970 Judy
Bloom novel of the same name it stars
Abby Rider forson as 11-year-old
Margaret along with Rachel McAdams as
her mother and Cathy Bates as her
grandmother I mean how amazing would it
be to have those two as your mom and
grandma anyway oh man does this capture
the awkwardness of so many things so
perfectly
um oh yeah can I just I'll just yep here
we
go this is always the tough bit I can't
even do this to this day okay all right
can I
see how's that feel I cannot wait to
take it off yeah welcome to
Womanhood the film is written for the
screen and directed by Kelly Freeman
Craig who teamed up with legendary
producer James L Brooks for this project
after previously working together on the
edge of 17 love that movie and with the
Tomato Meter score sniffing the 100%
Mark the critics use big words like
effervescent to describe this one saying
that it quote does full Justice to Judy
Bloom's seminal novel all right my
friends there you have it 2023 in a
movie nutshell TW a good year and one
that we can always look back on with
fond barbon Heimer memories I'm
obviously still bummed Barbie just made
the list at number 11 it was one of my
all-time favorites this year but for
more on all these movies that we
discussed today and the rest of this
epic year end list be sure to hit up
rotten tomatoes.com thanks for checking
out today's list until next time I'm
your host Naas Perez and we will see you
back here for more Rotten Tomatoes
[Music]
countdown